veronica tu voudrais venir avec moi ou
ça dans un endroit où je t'apprendrai
des choses tu aime apprendre pas vrai
quel genre de choses je vais t'entraîner
pour un travail très important et c'est
quel genre de travail
le genre que peu de gens s'affairent
ça c'est la nouvelle serveuse c'est quoi
c'est toute scission pour les blues
c'est son petit qu'est ce que j'ai raté
qu'est ce que vous faites là bas on
chasse
ou quel superbe perdre mich qui nous a
dégoté cette fois cette place est prise
tu fais quoi samedi soir je me lave les
cheveux
non ça c'est vendredi soir retrouvons
ici à 8 heures avec du rouge à lèvres et
les cheveux propres
c'est allez les mecs je m'appelle
veronica alors tu es prête à jouer
ça dépend du jeu maintenant tu vas
courir veronica et ensuite
ensuite on va de traquer
sun est réellement plus puissants que
les autres seul celui qui a la plus
grande volonté de l'emporter
tu vas devoir te débrouiller tout seul
pour cette mission
je m'en réjouis d'avancé
tai ji très intéressante